[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
amanda knox slams matt damon's movie
stillwater for profiting off her life
story
now asking does her own name belong to
her the film's director
previously saying her wrongful
conviction did influence him it served
as an initial inspiration point but not
much beyond that
the search is on for suspects accused of
shooting 10 people in new york city
then fleeing on mopeds seven innocent
bystanders wounded by gunfire
police say was meant for gang members
this is unacceptable on our streets of
new york city
and it has to stop shots fired
officer down trial begins for a
tennessee accused cop killer
taken into custody wearing the
sergeant's own handcuffs
a shocking admission by the defense
there's no question
that mr wiggins law and prime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer
co-host terry austin is off for the week
amanda knox is calling out the new movie
stillwater starring matt damon
claiming the film is trying to exploit
her life
i loved her i know you did but everybody
thinks that i killed her
in stillwater father matt damon travels
to france to visit his daughter in
prison
for the murder of her girlfriend a
murder she claims she did not commit
the movie's likeness to amanda knox's
own story now has knox asking
does my name belong to me my face what
about my
life story my story what does my name
refer to events
i had no hand in i returned to these
questions
because others continued to profit off
my name face
and story without my consent knox spent
nearly four years in an italian prison
for the murder of her roommate meredith
kercher in 2007.
she was exonerated on appeal in 2015
rudy good day was convicted in a
separate trial
the prosecution was never able to prove
that i was
that i participated in this case what
they were able to do
was raise enough smoke to suggest to
people that
there must be fire we spoke to knox last
year about the impact of coerced
confessions
it all derived from trying to force me
into
a sexual assault murder equation
that i certainly did not fit into knox
is now claiming she's continued to be
accused of knowing something i'm not
revealing
and haven't been involved somehow even
if i didn't plunge the knife
stillwater's director was asked last
month if the movie is at all related to
amanda knox
you know i was pretty fascinated with
the amanda knox case
back a long time ago and did a pretty
deep dive into it
and tracking it and just keeping up to
speed but you know
it was really just served as inspiration
at that point in a lengthy post on
twitter and medium
knox revealed that in the movie the
character asked the killer to help get
rid of her roommate
knock says by fictionalizing away my
innocence my total lack of involvement
by erasing the role of the authorities
in my wrongful conviction
mccarthy reinforces an image of me as a
guilty and untrustworthy person
my prosecutors downplayed
the actions of the actual killer
rudy g'day and they forced me
into the equation by bringing up
random unverified slanderous
details that ultimately were irrelevant
to the case
or were simply not true
joining us today is public defender
honor carlson and civil rights attorney
katie smith
honor you represented clients who have
found their way into a few headlines
could this be about how media portrays
cases in general
i think amanda knox um is stretching if
she thinks this is a documentary of
of her case i think everybody
understands law and order and shows like
that have a right to do a ripped from
the headline story
and and she's pointed out there are a
number of differences in this story
but i think she's making excellent
points from a very informed perspective
that having large widespread media
coverage of your own case
can affect whether you get a fair trial
it's part of why we ask
every jury when we when we pick them
what have you already been exposed to
what have you seen
about this case in the media because you
know just like you heard her say
in the interview there's already a
narrative operating and juries are
already very conscious of that so i
think
part of what she's doing here is maybe
asking for bearer trials and fair
portrayals going forward
absolutely everything points to knox
being at least the catalyst for this
movie
does she have any form of legal recourse
for this film
you know as anna said i don't believe it
rises to that level of using someone's
name or likeness in such a direct way
and i
originally thought of law and order too
they commonly get inspiration from
things that are in the headlines but
it's not a direct
rip and this also brought up one thing
for to me which is also the son of sam
laws
if there are convictions son of sam laws
which there are in most different states
prevent those who are convicted from
profiting directly
to their crimes so this implicates lots
of broader questions about
really what can be spoken about and who
can derive profit from it
absolutely well obviously keep eyes on
this and see what amanda knox's social
media is saying as this movie continues
to get views thank you both now to a
major update in wisconsin
where a man is charged with murdering
and dismembering his father law and
crimes angenette levy is here with the
latest on the halterson investigation
deputies in dane county wisconsin had
hoped to find krista halderson
alive but sadly they've announced that
part of
the human remains that they found have
now been identified as hers
now you may recall chandler halderson
who is christa halderson's son
he was charged with murder and
kidnapping
and he was also charged with
dismembering his father bart
now dane county officials say they'll
ask the district attorney to file
additional charges against chandler for
the murder of his mother
chandler halderson reported his parents
missing last month but deputies were
suspicious
of what he told them the sheriff told us
that a photo put chandler holderson
in the area where part of his dad's
remains were found
chandler holderson is right now being
held in the dane county jail
in the madison wisconsin area he is
expected back in court
early next month brian thanks angenet
turning now to more top legal news
robert kraft has scored another legal
victory
as a judge is ordering video of the new
england patriots owner
in a massage parlor be destroyed
craft face charges after hidden police
surveillance cameras at a massage parlor
allegedly caught men
paying for prostitution but both a trial
judge and appeals judge
ruled the sting operation violated
legitimate patrons rights to privacy
the video was suppressed and charges
against kraft were dropped
now a judge is again siding with kraft's
defense ordering the court return the
video to prosecutors for destruction
the video was never made public
marilyn manson is asking a judge to
dismiss a sexual assault lawsuit
filed by a game of thrones actress esme
bianco
the musician is now accusing bianco and
another unnamed woman
of spending months plotting workshopping
and fine-tuning consensual friendships
and relationships
into twisted tales bianco found the suit
earlier this year
accusing manson of attempting to force
her to perform sexual acts
including tying her to a prayer kneeler
beating her with a whip
apparently used by nazis and
electrocuting her
manson is also accused of sexual assault
by actor and activist
evan rachel wood still ahead on law and
crime daily
when rodney reed will learn his fate
after his hearing requesting a new trial
wraps up
but first a shooting that injured
bystanders caught in the crossfire
how police say the alleged suspects got
away after the break
[Music]
welcome back 10 people were shot over
the weekend in corona queens new york
law and crimes angela levy is here with
a video of the shooting and alleged
accomplishes
brian the nypd is calling this a
targeted gang-related attack but
unfortunately
seven innocent bystanders were wounded
and police are hoping that someone will
recognize the four men involved
saturday night around 10 p.m two masked
men with guns
walk toward a barber shop and start
shooting there was a party going on at
the restaurant
just a few stores away ten people were
shot
three of which are known trinitario gang
members
we believe there are seven unintended
targets nypd chief of detectives james
essex says the innocent bystanders shot
by these men
ranged in age from 19 to 72
men on mopeds picked up the shooters
there's just one common theme
i want to get out there that's a
recurring theme that keeps happening
and it has to stop throughout the city
that's gang members
that's guns multiple guns on the scene
scooters being used masks and lastly
unintended targets getting hit police
hope someone recognizes the men
in the video someone's going to see that
video they're going to see those still
photos they're going to say oh i know
that clothing or the video i know their
gate
i know so and so walks that way and
that's why we
are really really appealing to the
public
thankfully those seven innocent
bystanders who were shot
are expected to survive anyone with
information
about the shooting is asked to call new
york city's crime stoppers program
that's 1-800-577-tips
and katie smith is an attorney who is
here with us now katie
watching that video and hearing that
seven innocent people were struck by
gunfire what can we do do you think or
what can be done in new york city to
stop this kind of violence
you heard the chief of detectives say
they've had this issue in other parts of
the city
it's always a tough solution and i think
it's easier at least for me to approach
it from what we shouldn't do
rather than what we should do and i know
that the republican candidates leewa
suggested
that we should bring back stop and frisk
and that is simply
not the answer in times like this and
this is exactly when constitutional
rights become
slowly diminished as when people are
afraid what i do think we really need to
do is bolster
faith in the community with the police
because that's what really lacks
on the ground connections is one way to
take a step forward
yeah when you have your community
invested it sure helps and when they're
willing to cooperate with law
enforcement and pass along
that information of course thanks so
much katie brian we'll send it back to
you
thanks angenet a two-week hearing has
ended for a texas inmate who claims he's
innocent of raping and murdering a young
woman
rodney reed is on death row for the
murder of stacy stites in 1996.
reid's execution was stayed in 2019
after he was granted a new hearing
his attorney says evidence points to
other possible suspects
including stike's then fiance they also
say reed and steitz had a secret
consensual relationship
and that's why his dna was found on her
body but
prosecutors in stite's family says the
jury got it right
the judge has an august 31st deadline to
make a decision
the judge in robert durst's murder trial
has denied a request for a mistrial
after the millionaire claimed he was too
sick to testify durst has repeatedly
said he wants to testify in his own
defense
but a doctor said the stress of that
could kill him
durst is accused of killing his friend
susan berman to keep her quiet
about what she knew about his wife's
disappearance the state will rest its
case after
lapd detective louis romero finishes
testifying
an interview of durst following his
arrest in 2015
will play when romero's testimony
resumes
anna this is a new one i think for both
of us durst may not be around
if there is an appeal but let's just
imagine he will be but do you think a
higher court would approve of the
judge's ruling
to continue the case i think this is a
pretty problematic ruling i think um
in this particular case they have a lot
of documentation of his illness they
have
this isn't just based on an assertion by
the defense team
they have a recent examination from a
doctor at cedars-sinai
i i think that this could potentially
present a problem i mean
in in cases we always have a problem if
the defendant makes themself
absent from the case the case can go on
without them there
and that's what the prosecution is
alluding to that this person has
absented themselves from their own trial
but i think the defense has an excellent
case that this he's not he's not able to
participate through no fault of his own
all right we'll see how that argument
goes if this does end up going on appeal
thank you very much coming up on law and
crime daily
trial begins for an accused cop killer
the horrendous details in the death of a
tennessee deputy
and the shocking admission from the
defense after the break
[Music]
welcome back opening statements in the
tennessee trial of a defendant accused
of murdering a sheriff's deputy and
setting fire to his body
on monday a judge denied a defense
motion to delay the start of stephen
wiggins trial
due to the pandemic wiggins is charged
with first-degree murder vehicular arson
and abuse of a corpse for the death of
dickinson county
sheriff's deputy sergeant daniel baker
if convicted
wiggins could face the death penalty
baker was killed back in may 2018
prosecutors say baker was responding to
a report of a suspicious vehicle
driven by the defendant the defendant
removed a 45 caliber
high point semi-automatic pistol
as sergeant baker approached the
passenger side window
which had been rolled down the defendant
leveled off and shot
through the passenger side window
sergeant baker ran backwards from the
car
and issued his final words a warning
shots fired officer down
sergeant baker collapsed on the ground
still alive
the defendant exits the vehicle out of
the driver's side builder which he
previously said was broken he approaches
sergeant baker and at close range
executes
this is on video
prosecutors say the defendant that then
got into baker's
patrol vehicle drove it next to baker's
body loaded into the vehicle
and drove away
the defendant pretending to be law
enforcement answers
multiple radio calls from the dixon
county central dispatch
he's thinking clearly and quickly and he
responds
10-4 one in custody in route
the defendant answered sergeant baker's
cell phone
a call from deputy chris lashley
and he tells chris lashley pretending to
be sergeant-bacon
10-4 everything's okay he exits the
roadway
and he drives through a couple of fields
to a remote area that can't be seen from
the road
he gets out of the vehicle the defendant
then
sets fire to sergeant baker
and also the front seat of the bar he
closes the doors
locks the doors and flees
the defendant was arrested after two
days following one of the largest
manhunts in the state of tennessee
prosecutors say he was found in
possession of the murder weapon
and voluntarily gave a statement to
investigators
in that statement
he was asked why
did you walk up and shoot sergeant baker
in the head
close range and the defendant said
it's like a dog you don't let it suffer
when we come back the victim's widow
takes the stand the heartbreaking
testimony about the loss of a husband
father and law enforcement officer next
[Music]
back now to the trial of an accused cop
killer stephen wiggins
his defense attorney admitted his client
is the real killer but
pleading with the jury that he was not
premeditated
the proof in this case is gonna make you
happy
it's gonna make you angry and i know
that because it made me
and it wasn't until i was able to
learn more about stephen his life
history and his life course
that i was even able to begin to fight
how something like this could happen the
defense
does not intend to put forth witnesses
in this portion of the case
our intention is to cross examine
witnesses only to the extent
necessary to complete a picture
prosecutors say the defendant also stole
baker's backup weapon
a pistol his wife bought him for
christmas
one of the first well the first year we
were together um
i got him a a glock 357.
okay it so what did
daniel do with the glock 357 is that
something
it was to be used as a backup weapon
okay uh and
and would you see him carry it on a
daily basis as his backup weapon
yes i would see him with it um on
several occasions sometimes it stayed in
his police car so i
i didn't see it every day but i knew
that he had it how did you know that he
wanted a
357 as a backup weapon when there was
something that daniel wanted
then he made it known and he would drop
pins here and there too
i knew that's what he wanted he even had
it lined up at the
sportsman's store you know if i could if
she comes in this is the one i want
well did you attempt to fool him that
christmas as to
yes because that was i did that every
year
but um i would wrap something and if it
was small i would
wrap it in several sizes boxes
and i even put bricks in this one to
make it you know to try to mask what it
is
let's bring back civil rights attorney
katie smith and public defender honor
carlson
katie in the prosecution's opening they
said wiggins referred to the victim as a
dog
that he had to put him out of his misery
how much of an emotional impact do you
think this is going to have
on the jury during the openings brian i
think it's a huge emotional impact
you know it really shows the way he was
thinking about the victim at that time
and it's
really not doing any favors to the
defense
and i think immediately when you hear
that it feels so callous and the jury is
not supposed to of course consider
certain emotional aspects to things but
the jury is human
and hearing that is very disturbing and
it certainly goes to
this ultimate issue about whether or not
he really intended the killing
and i think that is not a good fact for
the defense yeah that dog statement
definitely is going to come back to bite
him because that shows intense in some
level of premeditation i think
anna the defense said they wouldn't
cross certain witnesses
and that they would not dishonor the
victim's memory your thoughts on the
defense's tactic here
so brian when i heard about this tactic
at first i thought that they were
referring to not wanting to
cross-examine police officers or other
potential witnesses in the case which i
think
in most cases would be a mistake you
almost never want
don't want to ask no questions you want
to maximize the impact of
one well-timed question their defense
here is
regarding premeditation regarding
whether he
um he had planned this and so asking a
police officer
well you never met stephen wiggins
before this you know before this
incident
or you weren't present on that day just
that one single question can have impact
but after watching uh the testimony from
what they call the spark of life witness
that's the the widow lisa baker
i think he's referring to reassuring the
jury he's not going to cross-examine the
grieving widow
and there really is nothing that that he
could accomplish by doing that
yeah i think it made a lot of sense i
think uh to some degree when you don't
have the facts on your side
as many defense attorneys often have in
cases
trying to find a middle ground with the
jury and say hey i'm not going to
overstep
my balance but i'm going to do my job
here i think that's a very smart move
thank you anna and katie and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you